macron 9477 froid soit 71 un choix clair
avec plus de 70% des voix nevers a
participé à la victoire d'emmanuel
macron une continuité après l'avoir déjà
porté en tête du premier tour
presque logique dans une ville dirigée
depuis 2014 par une liste qui rassemble
différentes sensibilités
nous avons lancé un tel mouvement en
2013 nous étions en marche avant de le
savoir puisque cela n'existait pas et
pour moi je le vis aussi pour l'ensemble
de l'équipe comme et bien un satisfécit
de cette voie nouvelle que nous avons
initié bien sûr emmanuel macron la
dérouler sur un autre challenge qui est
et sur un plan national mais l'ampleur
du score doit aussi beaucoup à
l'adversité surprise du premier tour
dans la nièvre avec une première place
et près de 25% des voix
marine le pen n'a pu confirmer cette
position avec 40% des suffrages dans le
département elle est cette fois
nettement devancé par le nouveau
président de la république
c'était absolument essentiel qu'il y ait
une très forte mobilisation pour que
l'extrême droite ne prennent pas le
pouvoir en france
une joie grave parce que d'abord la
campagne a été particulièrement lourde
et pénible
et puis que
je crois que comme tous les gens qui ont
soutenu emmanuel macron et comme lui
même
nous savons ce qui ce qui nous attend
malgré tout cette élection
présidentielle a confirmé l'ancrage
frontiste dans les zones rurales du
département un enjeu majeur des
législatives à venir
les thématiques du front national sont
les bonnes réponses aux problèmes
rencontrés dans la nièvre en france en
général
sommes installés durablement dans la
nièvre elles ont gagné dans une mini
havre diviser les prochaines semaines
s'annoncent cruciales
sans oublier que près de 14% des votants
ont fêté hier le choix d'un bulletin
blanc ou nul